goodbye my son
hopes and dreams troubled you you'll be
an outcast I'll kill him how I'll be a
god to them
what if a child dreamed of becoming
something other than what society had
intended what if a child aspired to
something greater
my son was in the bus
he saw what Clark did
you're the answer son you're the answer
to are we alone in the universe
just keep pretending I'm your son you
aren't my son I have to believe that you
were sent here for a reason and even if
it takes the rest of your life
you'll owe it to yourself to find out
what that reason is
how do you find someone who has spent a
lifetime covering his tracks
for some he was a guardian angel
for others a ghost we never quite fit in
you will give the people of Earth an
ideal to strive towards
they'll rise behind you it'll stumble
they will fall
but in time
they will join you in the Sun
in time it will help them
wanders
you believe your son is safe
I
my father believed if the world found
out who I really was
I'd reject me
he was convinced that the world wasn't
ready
what do you think
what's the S stand for it's not an S on
my world it means hope well here is an S
how about C excuse me
you